autre travail tiphaine cypher bonjour
c'est d'essayer de faire en sorte que
nos enfants continuent nous poser la
question mais peut-être d'avoir les
réponses sont parfois philosophique sur
parfois existentielle parents grands
parents vous tous qui étaient avec nous
vous dit youpi on va avoir les réponses
à ces questions grâce aux ouvrages que
vous avez sélectionné pour nous c'est ça
et oui parce qu'en fait les enfants nous
poser des questions très tôt et la
question qui nous traversent eux tous
c'est qui suis-je
comment est ce moi même et oui et
figurez-vous que dès la maternelle ça
commence et ce petit héros arbete lui il
se pose la question comment vais-je
m'habiller parce que dans ce livre
d'emilie grave est oui publié chez
kaléidoscope justement il ya un petit
chien comme ça qui arrive avec son
bonnet tricoté par sa grand mère il
adore ce bonnet mais un jour on lui dit
qu'elle est ringard c'est super de
travailler un gars que je veux dire
l'école saint-michel et ça l'amour dans
l'espace à l'aide alors il se met en
quête et du bonnet idéal du chapeau du
couvre chef qui le rendra à la mode et
il échoue
j'avais pensé à la mode des ringards je
garde ça vous est jamais arrivé
jamais de sport il a mordu son maître
était dragueur non je n'aime à la pointe
et bien lui il finit par trouver son
propre style
alors ce livre évidemment je le
conseille à tous les parents les grands
parents dès la maternelle des trois ans
c'est très joli vous voyez les
illustrations sont magnifiques
voilà on trouve des chapeaux tout ça
plus merveilleux les uns que les autres
et ça permettra et bien aux enfants de
découvrir qu'ils peuvent inventer leur
propre style j'adore le titre regard bon
méfiez-vous de l'armée le mot à l'ordre
du jour à la moitié des êtres des années
voilà nessakh tcc deuxième ouvrage ce
serait oui parce que là c'est pour les
enfants un peu plus grands à partir de
7-8 ans ça s'appelle les grandes
questions de williams essaie de
constance avec nilsen et akin directive
alors ça fait partie d'une collection
qui parle de philo est un peu le débat
il y a avec les jeunes enfants
juste avant le d'australie ça fait du
bien et louis élus
il se demande qui il est je vous ai dit
qu'on parlait de questions
existentielles
alors ne pas avoir tous les membres de
sa famille mais personne ne lui fait la
même réponse
on a eu 10 battue est mon meilleur ami
tué juste différent de moi mais ça lui
convient pas une du tout ses réponses
alors elle continue à se questionner et
nous en tant que lecteur on aimerait
exemple qui trouve la réponse parce que
nous aussi on voudrait savoir qui on est
alors c'est un très joli livre et les
illustrations sont magnifiques très très
douce et chaque personne est bien fait
preuve d'une grande tendresse envers le
petit garçon pour essayer de qu'il
trouve son chemin et qu'il trouve ses
réponses alors je ne vous dirai pas
qu'elle ait la réponse puisque
évidemment elle dépend des chèques
tu peux en tout cas ses conseils on nous
fait dans tous les formats il ya le
moyen il ya le petit format il ya aussi
le grand format chez le troisième grand
format et qui la font pas on m'a dit
figurines ou avec nos outils merci me
motive c'est un livre d'une saône et
loirienne roxane mariga liesse et d'une
coréenne 5 soon as je vais essayer de
cacher son nom à tavannes
je m'exerce pop dance et publié par
almunia jeunesse et revoyez les
illustrations sont magnifiques
alors là la réponse est bien mal à
trouver dans la méditation
mais la petite miyuki et bien justement
elle a du mal à méditer alors elle
demande à son grand-père de l'aider avec
lui dit mais observe la nature le temps
choiseul voilà et c'est une autre
manière de philosophie donc je me disais
que ça vous plairait aussi et alors
c'est à partir de 5 ans vous le voyez on
voyage parmi des illustrations
magnifiques
merci mme yu chi voilà merci tu fais une
dernière sélection peut-être avec un
autre ouvrage alors oui alors c'est une
collection en fait qui est plutôt à
partir du collège cette fois je me suis
dit on va parler aussi aux grands ça
s'appelle les grands entretiens des
milles et alors je voulais vous en
parler elle me tient à coeur parce que
c'est jean bojko vous le connaissez
peut-être le metteur en scène denis
vernet qui était basé à l'abbaye du
jouir qu'ils aient dit un jour mais pour
parler philosophie ou pour répondre aux
questions des des enfants et bien
pourquoi ne pas aller chercher un
collégien emile et lui présenter et bien
les grands philosophes les grands
penseurs de notre temps
et qu il leur pose en fait toutes les
questions qui lui viennent par la tête
le grand entretien des milliards à taux
plein on peut encore les commander en
s'adressant directement à l'abbaye du
jouir c'est super vraiment alors on
parle d'écologie c'est quoi prendre
c'est quoi l'écologie c'est quoi être
riche et en bonne santé
voilà c'est à partir du collège mais
c'est aussi pour les adultes je vraiment
je vous les conseille
c'est super merci tiphaine voilà
beaucoup de réponses à des questions pas
toujours évidentes que nous posent nos
enfants et nos petits-enfants